الدولية هي الحكومة الفيدرالية
في اتفاقية الذخائر العنقودية
انضم في عام 2010 لذلك هذا هو
موقف الحكومة الفيدرالية في هذا الشأن
أعتقد أن هذا يكفي عندما يتعلق الأمر بالأسلحة
توثيقه بشكل مختلف عن ذلك
وهم ينتمون إلى جمهورية ألمانيا الاتحادية
الولايات المتحدة وأوكرانيا لا تتفقان
توسيع اتفاقية الذخائر العنقودية
مثلك ونحن على يقين من ذلك
أصدقاؤنا الأمريكيون يتخذون القرار
حول تسليم المقابلة
لم تجعل الذخيرة سهلة
دولي
لدينا أيضا لهم في واحدة خاصة
كوكبة للقيام بمجموعات أوكرانيا
ذخيرة لحماية نفسك
عدد السكان المدنيين واحد هو حوالي واحد
استخدامها من قبل حكومتك
تحرير أراضينا نحن
لذلك يجب أن نأتي مرة أخرى
تصور روسيا في واحدة
الحرب العدوانية على القانون الدولي
أوكرانيا بالفعل على نطاق واسع
تم استخدام ذخيرة واسعة النطاق
يقابل
[موسيقى]